we're told this table gives a few values
of function f it tells us what f of x is
equal to that x is equal to 2 3 4 and 5.
which condition would allow you to
conclude that there exists a maximum
value for f over the closed interval
from 2 to 4. so pause this video and see
if you can figure it out
so you might already remember if we're
trying to conclude that there exists
anytime people are talking about there
exists something over an interval we're
probably dealing with some type of an
existence theorem and if we're talking
about the existence of a maximum or a
minimum value for a function over an
interval that means that we're talking
about the extreme value theorem or we
are likely talking about the extreme
value
theorem
and in order to apply the extreme value
theorem sometimes abbreviated evt
we need to know that our function is
continuous over this closed interval
so in order to do that we need to know
that f
is continuous
over
our closed interval here over 2 to 4 the
closed interval from 2
to 4.
so let's see which of these will allow
us to conclude this because if we're
able to conclude this then we're able to
apply the extreme value theorem which
tells us that there exists a maximum
value for f over that interval
all right choice a says f is increasing
in the open interval from two to three
and decreasing on the open interval from
three to five
now you could completely this doesn't
tell us that we're definitely continuous
over that interval over over two to four
so i would rule that out you could
definitely still be discontinuous and
statement a still being true so i'm
going to rule that one out
f is continuous over the closed interval
from two to five
well if we're continuous over the closed
interval from two to five we're
definitely continuous over a subset over
that over the closed interval from 2 to
4.
and so if we're able to make that
if we if we know that then we can
we can use the extreme value theorem
we've met the condition for the extreme
value theorem to say that there exists a
maximum value for f over that interval
so i like this one let's just look at
this last one f is differentiable over
the open interval
from 2 to 4
and at x is equal to two
so this is close because
differentiability does imply continuity
but it isn't telling us what's happening
at x equals four we could still be
discontinuous at x equals four we're
just differentiable
for every point up to four because it's
talking about an open interval so this
is close if they said differentiable
over the closed interval from two to
four then this would allow us to
conclude because differentiability over
an interval implies continuity but i'm
going to rule this one out because it
does not ensure continuity
at our right boundary at x equals 4.
let's do another one of these
h is a differentiable function and once
again they've given us what our phalli
what our function h is equal to at
certain sampled x points x values
clyde was asked whether there's a
solution to h of x is equal to negative
on the interval from the closed interval
from negative 1 to 3. this is his
solution and then we're asked is clyde's
work correct if not what is his mistake
and then they give us some choices but
before even looking at the choices let
us
pause this video and see if what clyde
is saying makes sense and if it if it
doesn't make sense try to pinpoint where
he messed up what step did he make the
wrong conclusion if he made any mistake
at all
all right
so the first thing he did is he said
look negative 2 we want to see is there
an x value where h of x is equal to
negative 2.
so first he says well negative 2 is
between h of negative 1 and h of 3. so
let's see h of negative 1 is
two
and h of three is negative five and he
is right that negative three
or sorry negative two sits right in here
so if we were to so negative 2 is right
in between these two values it's right
in between h of negative 1 and h of 3.
since h is differentiable
we know it is continuous on that closed
interval
that's right we were just talking about
that differentiability implies
continuity continuity does not always
imply differentiability you can't make
that assumption but differentiability
implies continuity if we're
differentiable over interval we're
definitely continuous on that interval
and so he's right here that so far step
one and step two we can conclude that we
are continuous over the closed interval
from negative one to three
and then he says the extreme value
theorem guarantees a solution to h of x
equals negative 2 on that closed
interval
so this feels a little bit fishy because
the extreme value theorem says that it
says well if we can if we meet our
conditions and we did for even the
extreme value theorem we're continuous
on that closed interval it says that
we're going to have a well-defined
maximum and minimum value on that closed
interval but we don't care about minimum
and maximum values here what we care
is that we take on an intermediate value
in that interval and a value in between
h of negative 1 and h of 3 possibly what
each of those boundaries as well
and so
he's applying the wrong theorem it
should be the intermediate value theorem
i'll just abbreviate that as i
vt is what he should be saying the
intermediate value theorem because we
are continuous on the closed interval it
says that we are going to take on every
value between h of negative 1 and h of 3
and negative 2 is in is one of those
values between h of negative 1 and h of
3. and so if he just wrote intermediate
value theorem instead he would have been
correct so
let's see which choice cora is
is consistent with what we just wrote
he's definitely not correct
step one wasn't correct wasn't incorrect
two is between h negative two is between
h of negative one and h of three
step two was
was actually correct we know that
differentiability implies continuity
step three is incorrect yes he applied
the wrong theorem